i'm just starting the live stream now
i'll confirm once it's uh up and running
thank you
there's a slight time lag we're ready
chairman
welcome to the rochford district
council's remote meeting
of the licensing and appeals
subcommittee and welcome to anybody
watching this for your live stream
good afternoon my name is councillor
phil shaw
and i am the chairman of the license and
appeals committee
the other members are if you could
induce yourself please
councillor michael hoyer and councillor
daniel lefty
um we've also got a committee's legal
adviser
mr chris irwin
today's hearing is
from the meeting of the first of the
seventh 19
2021. the purpose of the hearing today
is to consider an application for a
premises
license made by mr caesar
tsuzulukia relating to the premises
known as vintage off license
105 london road rally
excuse me chairman glad to say that it's
not steve greener we've got
clarice brooke today is a licensing
officer
yeah thank you
right could the council license officer
please introduce themselves hi
i'm carys brooke and i'm the licensing
officer at rochford district council
uh have you anybody else with you today
and were you recording any witnesses
no i think uh could the applicant please
introduce himself
good afternoon chair i'm graham hopkins
from gt licensing consultants
to my left is mr toslikaya
and his son canberra is to his left
camber is here to help his dad with
translation where necessary
thank you and have you any other
witnesses or anything you're going to
call today
no jeff thank you
happy any uh anybody and from the any
responsible authorities of
today no
are there any interesting parties
no right chairman there is
if you could allow her to introduce
herself please
right yes thank you chairman i'm
danielle belton uh representing a number
of local residents to the store
thank you thank you
and is the premises license holder
in attendance
chair there is no premises license
holder it's a new application
right okay yes okay i just wanted to go
right
right the proceedings today will follow
item three of the agenda and i will draw
the attention to everybody to the
following
15 minutes permitted to the applicant to
present their submissions
15 minutes to any responsible authority
and 15 minutes to any interesting
parties
right could i ask the um
license officer to present their
item please yeah okay
so uh this is an application for a grant
of a premises license made under section
17 of the licensing act 2003
the application was submitted to the
licensing authority
by gt licensing consultants which is
graeme hopkins
on behalf of mr toslokaya it refers to
the premises to be known as the vintage
off license 105 london road
rayleigh the premises to which the
application relates comprises of a
retail unit with the intention to
operate
a one-stop convenience shop and off
licence
the premise is located within a small
parade of shops along london road
the application is for the following
licensable activities
which is the supply of alcohol and
that's off sales only
for monday to sunday from 9 a.m
to 11 p.m
the application was assessed by essex
police and they confirmed they have no
representations
it was also assessed by the council's
environmental health service
and they agreed conditions with the
applicant
we have received 13 representations
which have raised concerns in relation
to the following licensing objectives
which are prevention of crime and
disorder prevention of public nuisance
all of these can be found in appendix e
it's proposed that the committee
resolves the application with one of the
following
options to grant the application subject
to such conditions as are consistent
with the operating schedule
modified to such extent as members
consider necessary
or the promotion of the licensing
objectives and any mandatory condition
that must be included or to exclude from
the scope of the license any of the
licensable activities to which the
application relates
or to reject the application
or to adjourn the hearing to a specified
date or arrange for a hearing to be held
on the specified additional dates
that's the report thank you i have any
of the committee members any questions i
wish to ask
i have no questions at this point
chairman no
thank you none at this point chairman
thank you have the
applicants any questions i wish to ask
no chair thank you very much as
anybody else any questions i wish to ask
no thank you thank you
why could i ask the applicant to
present their submissions please thank
you chair
um if if i can start by saying that mr
toshaya is a
highly experienced retail operator chair
and also an experienced off-license
operator
he has successfully operated a
convenience store and off license
within the london borough of barnet in
east coat for a number of years where he
is the dps
no issues arose at that shop and there
were no breaches and had been no
breaches
of his license he's also successfully
operated a large convenience store
in newham for over 16 years
and where we successfully obtained a new
premises license for off sales of
alcohol
in april this year mr tosh lakaya is the
dps
there um despite the fact that that shop
is an accumulative impact so mr toslokai
was able to demonstrate
to the subcommittee at the hearing that
his shop would not add
to negative in cumulative impact now of
course this shop is not in a cumulative
impact zone
um and mr tosukaia has operated that
shop in newark for 16 years and held a
personal license for 13 years
so he brings his very considerable
experience in retail and
licensed premises chair to his new
business at 105
london road chair members will be aware
that this
application under the license must be
dealt with purely on its own merits
and as i've said it's not in a
cumulative impact zone so there's no
um subjection to a rebuttable
presumption to refuse the license test
before we submitted this application as
you've heard um
we did discuss this application in depth
with essex police licensing
and the council's licensing team
you will have seen from the agenda that
mr talk and you've heard from ms brooke
that
mr tosliker has agreed a number of
conditions relating to
the prevention of public nuisance with
the environmental health department
chair the hours requested for off sales
valve on the proposed opening hours are
the same from 9 to 11 days a week
and i would suggest to the panel that
the hours are traditional
off license hours and are not excessive
for this location
rochford district council has no
framework hours specified in its
statement of licensing policy
but the hours are within those of most
licensing authorities in the
uh sort of south essex london area where
those authorities do
have residential areas with framework
hours
framework hours that would apply in
areas such as london road
so we would submit to you that the hours
are are reasonable and
uh sensible for this location
mr totokai has offered a comprehensive
list of conditions
which were discussed with the police
in his operating schedule to fully
promote the licensing objectives
and they include those discussed with
essex police one of which was that there
shall be no sale of single cans or
bottles of beer
i won't go through the conditions in
detail i'm sure the panel have read read
them but just to
brush through them um does include a
comprehensive cctv system with the
conditions
that you would expect 31-day storage
there's a night camera cover in the back
there are two cameras covering the front
of the shop
that would aid the police if they were
incidents on the pavement
comprehensive staff training and
refresher training challenge 25 proof of
age scheme
i've mentioned the no single cancel
bottles of beer etc
bottle marking and a maximum of 25 to
the retail area to be used for the
display of alcohol
thereby preventing the shop from
becoming a bottle shop this is actually
a convenience store similar to these
other shops
um sales are excuse me they will sell a
range of foodstuffs groceries frozen
products soft drinks etc
um and alcohol will be uh that we're
asking for is an addition to those so
that we can operate as the uh
one-stop convenience shop concept
especially given the location with
rayleigh station not so far up the road
and i can tell the panel that the
intended customer base is local people
and
passing footfall chair there are no
representations against this application
for new premises licensed from any
responsible authority that includes the
police and
the council's licensing team and i would
suggest to you that's because the
application hasn't caused them any
concerns that
problematic issues will arise if the
license is granted
or that the licensing objectives will
not be fully promoted
excuse me there are a number of
representations from local residents
and on behalf of mr toslokai i can
advise the panel
that uh via your licensing team we did
reach out
to the residents who have objected via
email inviting them to engage with us
and to attempt mediation and i am
grateful to
miss brooke for forwarding the emails on
for us
and the advice from her and her
colleagues and from the police
i can tell the panel that
disappointingly not one of the residents
who've objected engaged with us or
contacted us
but i bear you ask you to bear in mind
when you're deliberating later
that for his part mr tostakaya has tried
to engage in accordance with the
home secretary's guidance before turning
the chair to the
other person's representations i would
like to address some points
very briefly um residents refer to there
being no need for another shot
the panel will be aware that you can't
legally consider that
the trade need is specifically excluded
under the licensing act
and under the guidance as a matter
purely for the commercial matter
for the commercial market to decide it
is not a licensing matter
commentary parking generally can't be
considered because again the guidance
suggests that other
controlled regimes should not be bolted
or duplicated onto licensing
chair other persons the residents have
commented on what happens
other premises or has happened another
premise
again i suggest those comments should
not and cannot be considered either
he said this is a new application for a
premises license and as i've already
said
must be considered purely on its own
merits
mr toslukaya cannot be held responsible
for what's happened to other premises
either recently or in the past
premises the representations are of
themselves highly speculative
and while there is of course case law
allowing speculation
um to be introduced parties are still
required to provide
some evidential base to support their
statements in their representations
in this case no evidential bases have
been provided no reports to the police
complaints to trade her to
trading standards about underage or to
environmental health about noise
and i would remind the panel the the
resident representations are
not supported by representation from the
police licensing
environmental health training standards
etc and i ask you to bear that in mind
in deliberation i understand
as well that the arrival of license
which is mentioned by all the residents
or most of the residents
on the same parade submitted a petition
against their clients application
but it was rejected by the licensing
authority as non-compliant
now i can tell you it was of some worry
to us and specifically to my
mr toddler kaya that someone i'm not
naming the shop
um involved obviously and i'm not naming
individuals but somebody from that shop
visited my clients builders while the
shop refurbishment was going on
was very angry uh at the builders and
stated that they would not get a license
and they would do all they could to stop
one being granted highly uh a good
neighbour neighborly thing to do i would
suggest to the panel that's somewhat
irresponsible
um i we do wonder whether uh looking at
some of the reps
mr hopkins can i interject that that is
not part of the application
no but we wanted you to know chair
because i'm the partner
i've got um later
two or three minutes to sum up but sorry
this is not actually part
of the application okay well we won't
mention that i was just looking at the
representations that's what i was going
to mention anyway
um moving on from that and you've got
one minute left
okay you've got an application by a
responsible operator
specific points raised by residents
addressed if you look at the
uh the conditions offered under a sales
asb
all addressed by the conditions we've
approved agreed with environmental
health and proposed
sensible hours share a responsible
operator no evidence whatsoever to to
bear out that
he's going to add to problems in the
area or anything
else it's a one-stop shop people can go
in there buy their groceries
and buy some beers a bottle of wine to
take home it's that sort of approach
comprehensive training as i've mentioned
no past record of mr tuttle's
tostakaya selling to underage or to
drunken persons
um concerns about children i would
submit are addressed with the conditions
you'll see on there
ditto with anti-social behavior
condition on there to address that
people they will go out and engage with
people if they're people lighting
outside
ask them to move away and not serve them
if they don't
that's that's the basis of our case
chair and we would ask you to grant the
licensing form thank you thank you
members there's any questions to the
applicant
oh yes chair i just got one um okay i
know
the the um
the representations made and
particularly around the opening hours
and the fact we don't have any
thing to to um limit them in that sense
however i just wonder what the
applicant's thoughts were concerning
opening until eleven o'clock and the
fact and again i take
the representations made by graham
hopkins
but the the fact that the tesco
express has had to employ security
guards on a couple of nights a week
um friday and saturdays i believe um
because of the problems they've
encountered have you
what thoughts have you had about
possible encounters
like that
thank you councillor um i mean mr mr
tulsa kaya
i've just just had a quick word with you
about that they would consider having a
security guard maybe for the later hours
on a friday and saturday uh
subject as you'll you'll be aware there
is a problem with sia staff at the
moment because of the
situation with door supervisors et
cetera et cetera but yes it's something
he would think about and consider
they are proposing to have minimum staff
i understand be about three staff
especially
fridays and saturdays and there is a new
manager going
in there who will become the dps if the
license is granted
to deal specifically with that shop and
concerns of residents
we wouldn't want to cut the hours back
specifically at this stage
hey thank you
daniel if you any no no
questions if answered all my questions i
had thank you
that's the licensing officer and any
questions today
no thank you
right um interesting parties if
you have you got a
thank you and thank you for your time
so i'm here representing a number of
residents who
came by me at my then position as ward
counsellor
um as didn't want to come forward
themselves for fear of repercussion
and for whatever reason they they may
seem that
that was a risk so that's why i'm here
today
um essentially not to not to reiterate
all of the points in the representations
because i'm sure everybody around the
table has read them and understands them
but the the absolute main concern from
the residents that i
spoke to that i'm representing and those
that put their own
um letters in is around the opening
hours
people understand that you would take
steps in regards to
um the licensing and the requirements
there the cctv you've mentioned
the fact that you've liaised with
interested parties such as
the police and security and whatnot but
essentially
it all relates to the 9 a.m to 11 p.m
seven days a week residents feel it's
excessive and
ultimately it's going to lower their
standard of living
there are young families that live above
and around the premises
there are many types of people that live
in this area
and the the overriding concern is that
being open seven days a week until 11 pm
will reduce the standard of living and
will cause a concern
um in regards to anti-social behaviour
the fact that there's a senior school
opposite raises other concerns
i appreciate everything that's been said
by the applicant
in terms of the steps they would take
but ultimately what the residents have
asked
is that the panel consider are the
opening hours
reasonable for the location and given
the other
the other businesses in the on the
parade
um i have mentioned the other
convenience store on the strip but i'll
completely
understand that's not relevant for the
licensing point of view because it's a
commercial
interest and but ultimately
like i say anti-social behaviour hours
of operation
noise and parking were the main
overriding
concerns that were replicated by
multiple residents
if there could be consideration given to
hours of trade
i think that would appease a lot of the
residents concerns
because 11 p.m seven days a week
it is late there will be extra trade
there will be extra noise there will be
extra cars
and people have lived here for many
years and are worried that their
standard of life will be hindered as a
result
so i would just ask the committee to
consider that we're making the decision
thank you
any members of the committee any
questions i wish to ask
no chairman no chairman thank you
right can i ask the um licensed officer
for a viewers closing statement
sorry chair could i just interject there
did you just want to ask the other
parties if they have any questions for
um the um interested party
oh certainly sorry yes
anybody any questions for the interested
parties
yes chair if i may through you um the
counselor belton mentioned i'm sorry i
hope i got the name right
um uh mentioned that residents were
concerned about
retaliation i mean has she got any
different
definite evidence or any suggestions
that
residents would have anything to fear
from mr tosla gaia i've known him for a
considerable
amount of time and he's not that sort of
person so we just wonder whether that
is evidence-based or or just a
speculative comment that they've thrown
in
the residents that i spoke to i asked
them to i advise them to put their names
and addresses forward so that they could
be individually represented
but they all said they were they were
concerned of fear of repercussion
they didn't give specifics and to be
honest i didn't go into detail because i
felt it would be speculative
ultimately i think as per anything some
sometimes people don't want to put their
name forward
for fear of of being sort of reprimanded
as a
as a nuisance or or worse
and i certainly am not pointing any
allegations i'm just stating the reason
why residents contacted me
in my vein capacity as ward counsellor
thank you
chair may i just ask um councillor
belton if my clients but
sorry um it's mrs belton now
she was a councillor she's i'm sorry
yeah so just uh to clarify the position
my chairman i think um she's actually i
think
sorry council belter i think you are a
counselor still aren't you
although not on uh
a couple of changes but i'd like to just
ask councillor belton i'll
still say councillor belton um if she
thinks it would make any difference to
the residents the changes we propose
councillor belton would be to reduce the
sunday hours
um both trading and opening to nine
o'clock 2100 hours
and to employ barely minded a
colleague's question on the panel
um to employ a security guard on friday
and saturday nights
from eight until close would you think
that would
go towards addressing the residents
concerned those two changes
but they they would certainly help and
ultimately
it's the shall we call it the school
nights it's the the sunday to thursday
that i think with a real concern being
over
open until 11 o'clock especially through
summer months
people have got their windows open and
the extra football
parking and sales etc they were
concerned was going to be
like i say detrimental to their standard
of living there's a lot of commuters
that live in the area that work
exceptionally early hours and obviously
school children
and so whilst the 9 pm on a sunday
would help what they were ultimately
asking for is like the other shots in
the parade
that 9 pm certainly on a on a week night
would be adhered to thank you
right go back to um
the any closing remarks
uh no not from me i think
mr hawkins
yeah is it right that councillor belton
should go first
and we go last i don't know maybe the
legal officer can advise
uh chair i think that's a matter for
yourself but yeah i think and that would
probably make sense if the applicant
went last
okay
okay cancer belton yeah just just uh
just to
summarize and ultimately many residents
i spoke to were
were happy and excited that there was a
new shop in the parade
nobody likes empty premises and
personally as a town councillor and
someone that's really cares about our
local economy
i'm i wish you the best with the with
the business itself
from a resident's point of view like i
say the main concern is around the 11 pm
closing
seven days a week because it really
could be impactful
thank you
i miss hopkins thank you chair
well you you've got up to two minutes
for your closing
statement thank you i'll keep it short
as possible um so we're offering to
reduce sunday to
opening and trading hours to 2100 hours
and a condition that there'll be a
security guard friday and saturday from
200 hours to close opening hours of
course per se
are not licensed and you would only be
looking at the
trading hours and such um we don't want
to reduce the hours
sorry monday till saturday for obvious
reasons new shop uh viability et cetera
et cetera we've offered
those new changes you have an
experienced operator
no evidential basis before you
whatsoever to suggest that
mr toslokaya will not uphold the license
objectives we say he will
uh past experiencing in show that
he wants to get on well it goes without
saying with the very resonance
they'll be his customer base we hope um
so he's not going to be
there to upset them but to provide a
service to them
a one-stop shop where they can go and do
everything if they don't want to go to
the other premises we won't talk about
um the supermarket so they'll have a
choice
based on the conditions offered the fact
you've got no uh representations of the
police etc
um they're satisfied he's not going to
undermine the objectives or cause the
problem
i think the strength is in the case and
we would ask you to
grant the the license i have mentioned
that he's going to put
a new manager in the shop uh who holds a
personal license is experienced
um and will be employing four staff at
the premises but we will have a dps in
there we'll be concentrating on that
shot
thank you chair thank you
right the committee will now adjourn to
to consider the case
and we may request that our legal
advisor attends with us
for any legal advice we will return in
approximately
30 minutes for that
um to and after decision this will also
be sent to you in writing
you do not have to wait but you are
welcome to do so
thank